around 61% of all curbside rubbish is  compostable so by using your organics  bin you can make a huge difference to  what gets sent to landfill let's start  with the items that can't go into your  green bin and should be put in the  rubbish  these include non-compostable garden  wastes such as cabbage tree leaves and  flex grass clippings from lawns that  have been sprayed in the last six weeks  and compostable packaging including  cornstarch bags such as this items that  say commercially compostable can't be  processed locally and should go in the  rubbish so what should go into your bin  food scraps including meat or fish bones  compostable garden waste in food soil  paper napkins or cardboard containers  such as pizza boxes all these items  should be loose not in bags but you can  wrap veggie scraps and newspaper to  learn more or to sign up for collection  reminders visit Waimakariri govt TVNZ  forward slash rethink rubbish  [Music]